hey this is pressure Locker the shape
below consists of six congruent
rectangles
if a single rectangle has a perimeter of
222 what is the perimeter of the shape
that is what is the perimeter of the
shape I've highlighted in blue can you
figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution it first seems like there is
not enough information to solve this
problem because the rectangles overlap
in odd places but in this video I will
present two ways you can solve this
problem the first is to over count the
perimeter and then subtract out the
overlapping segments the shape consists
of six rectangles so we could over count
as the perimeter of six rectangles we
didn't need to subtract out the
overlapping segments when two rectangles
overlap we have to subtract two times
the length of the overlapping segment
this is because the segment will overlap
for two different rectangles for example
if we look at the top brick we have one
of its length being overlapping with
another two rectangles so to account for
this overlapping region we need to
subtract out two lengths in the bottom
rectangle we have another overlapping
length so we again subtract out two
lengths we have the same thing in the
other bottom rectangle in the middle
three rectangles we have an overlapping
height since this overlaps for two
rectangles we subtract out two heights
we do the same for the other rectangle
in the middle and we do the same for the
overlapping height at the bottom in
total we need to subtract six lengths
and six Heights which is equivalent to
subtracting out the perimeter of three
rectangles because each rectangle has a
perimeter equals to two lengths and two
Heights ultimately the shapes perimeter
is equal to that of six rectangles minus
three rectangles which equals three
rectangles
thus the perimeter is three times two
hundred twenty two which is 666
this is one way to get the answer now
let me present another way this involves
rearranging the shape to create a new
shape whose perimeter will be easier to
solve but will be the same as the
original shape the key insight is if we
slide a rectangle along an overlapping
line the perimeter will remain unchanged
for example if I slide the top rectangle
along the overlapping line the perimeter
will be unchanged we can do the same
thing for the bottom two rectangles we
have simply shifted the point at which
they overlap we have not made these
breaks to go off the edge we simply
shifted their locations along the points
at which they already overlapped so we
now have a new shape which has exactly
the same perimeter as the beginning
shape the new shape is as wide as three
rectangle lengths and it is as tall as
three rectangle Heights so we can count
this will have the perimeter of three
rectangles alternately we can see that
the boundary consists of six different
lengths I'll count them one two three
four five and six and it consists of six
different heights one two three four
five six so again this is equivalent to
three rectangles therefore the shapes
perimeter is equal to the perimeter of
three rectangles which is three times
222 which equals 666 did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch me on my blog my your
assumes that you can follow on Facebook
Google+ and patreon you can catch me on
social media at pressure saw Walker and
if you like this video please check out
my books there are links in the video
description